さて早速ですけれども今スライドで示して
いる金額これは何を示しているものかと
思われますでしょうか
なかなか金額が大きいのでパッとイメージ
がつきづらいのかなと思いますけれども
こちらは
過去10年間の世界における災害による
被害額になっています
こちらのスライドは
災害ごとの経済的損害を
示しているものです
最近
災害によって
非常に多くの被害が出ております
特にこの緑色に示している機構天候に関連
する災害が非常に多く発生していることが
わかるかなと思います
一方こちらは日本で
起こってしまっている
災害によって生じてしまった
被害額を示している
グラフです
見てわかりますようにこちらも非常に多く
の
被害が出ていることがわかります
ただちょっと金額が大きすぎてちょっと
ピンとこないんじゃないかなと思います
こういった災害は直接的な被害もあるん
ですけれども間接的な被害もあります皆
さんにとって特に実感することと言います
と
物価ではないでしょうか
昨今非常にいろんなものが物価が上がって
困ってるっていう事があるかなと思うん
ですけれどもこちらのグラフが示してい
ます青色の方が全体的な物価の価格の上昇
です
これは消費者物価指数を表したものです
オレンジ色が食料です
食料の物価が非常に上がっていることが
わかるかなと思います
こういった物価の上昇の影響というのは
もちろん自然災害だけではなく
紛争であったりまた最近の新型コロナ感染
症
それの影響に受けて
経済的な不況が起こってこういったことは
複合的にいろんな物価に影響を与えてい
ます
こういった外部ストレスが生じている中で
我々はレジリエンス力を高める必要性と
いうのが出ています
防災の分野でレジリエンス力を考える中で
3つの要素があります
自助共助という言葉でどこかで聞いたこと
があるかもしれません
次女っていうのは自分で助ける共助って
いうのは
友達知り合いによって助けてもらう
控除は公ですね行政によって助けてもらう
こういった3つの要素を
挙げていくことが防災分野の中で
レジリエンス力を高めることにつながると
いうふうに議論されています
こちらは
阪神淡路大震災におけるその公助自助共助
の主体がどうなっているかってことを表し
たものです
若い方は阪神淡路大震災というのを経験さ
れてないのでなかなか時間されないかも
しれないですけども私自身は高校ちょうど
3年生の時ちょっと受験だったんです
けれどもセンター試験を受けた次の日に
この阪神淡路大震災が起こりました
ちょうどビルでビルが震災で倒れている時
にその
中で
受験の男に向かったことを記憶しています
この阪神淡路大震災では
結局自助という自分で
助かった人たちが6割そして知り合いなど
で助かって
方達が3割そして公序というのが非常に
少なく1割程度になっています
私自身も当時西宮に住んでましたので家の
周りたくさんの家が全開しました実際自分
たちで
逃げたり助けたりそして知り合い隣人で
助け合ったりしたことも記憶しています
こういったこともあってやはりいろんな
災害何か外部ストレスがある際には自分
自身でなんとかしないといけないとそう
いったことがあるかなと思います
少しちょっと私自身の話で恐縮ですけれど
もこういった震災の経験そして当時高校3
年生で受験だったんですけれども当時は
医学部を実は目指してました
そういった中でも医学部に進学することは
失敗して
改めて自分自身が何をしたいのかという
ことを
考え直すきっかけにもなりましたその中で
自分自身は
結局土木工学に進むことになったんです
けれどもというのは私自身いろんなところ
に行っていろんな風景地域
独特の街並みとか
歴史的な文化とかそういったことを見たり
知ったり体験したりすることがすごく好き
だったので土木工学の中でもまちづくりの
研究をしてきています
実際大学の時には勉強であったり研究と
いう称していろんなところに旅しました
バックパッカーで海外で
友達であったり自分一人でいろいろ
旅をしたりしました
そういった海外の経験の中で仕事としては
将来
海外で働きたいなという漠然な思いもあっ
たので当時は国際機関などで働きたいなっ
ていう思いがありまして学部時代も
インターンシップなどをして国連
軍を道に
臨んでいましたで実際そのインターンの
経験を生かして少しですけれども日本に
ある国連事務所で
働いたりもしていました
その中で国連を目指していこうという中で
当時まだ大学
博士課程に
在学してたんですけれどもそこで大学の
海外プロジェクトがベトナムで立ち上がる
ということもあって
幸いにそこのプロジェクトの担当の教員と
して
採用されることになりましてそこから大学
教員の道っていうものが今につながってい
ます
その大学でのプロジェクトで関わる
ベトナムなんですけれどもベトナムって
いうのは皆さん行ったことある方も
いらっしゃるかもしれませんか非常に
レジリエンス力が高い国の一つかなと思い
ます
歴史的にもアメリカであったり中国であっ
たりとかと紛争したりまた一時フランスで
あったり日本にも植民地化されてた時も
ありました
またその植民地化時代の時には
文字も
漢字からアルファベットに変更させられ
たりとかそういったいろんな外部的な
ストレスもありましたしもちろん自然災害
も非常に起こる地域です
まあそういったいろんな外部的なストレス
がありながらもベトナムは
柔軟に対応しながら時には対抗しながら今
のベトナムを作ってってます
このベトナムで先ほどご紹介した
プロジェクトを実施しているんですけれど
も私自身はベトナムの中部を中心に
活動をしていました
このベトナム中部市になるんですけれど
もっていうのが
ちょうどそのベトナム戦争の北ベトナム
ベトナムの
軍事境界線の近くということもあって非常
にせん断時
被害を被った
町の一つでもあります
またちょっとちょうどこのベトナムの地図
のこの辺にあたるんですけれども非常に
こう国境と海が近いところですので自然
災害も非常に起こりますしまたラオスとの
国境も近いということでいろんな少数民族
が住んでいる地域もあります
こういったいろんな外部的なストレスで
あったりとかがある地域なんですけれども
こちらで暮らしの安全を
維持するまちづくりを実現するって言った
プロジェクトを現地の大学の先生住民の方
と一緒に
研究をしてきています
いくつが活動あるんですけれどもその中の
一つをちょっとご紹介したいなと思います
こちらの今示していますスライドの写真は
本ハムラという増えしからだいたい50
キロぐらいに位置する山間部にあるんです
けれどもいわゆる
少数民族の村の一つになっています
ベトナムは実は約54の
民族があると言われているんですけれども
そのうち9割が金属と言われるいわゆる
中華系の民族になってるんですが残り1割
ですねが
53の
少数民族にが構成されていると言われてい
ます
その少数民族のうち4つの
民族がいわゆる
定住化政策と言われる政策の中で新しい
ものが作られてそこで
村が構成されているんですけどもそこで
暮らしの安全ということをテーマに
プロジェクトが実施され地域の人たちが
主体に
活動する中で
我々外部社が参加するそして
大学の学生がインターンシップとして参加
することで実際の
暮らしであったりレジデンス力っていう
ものを研究学んでいくといった
プロジェクトになっています
先ほどご紹介したフエデの活動以外にも
ベトナムではダナンでプロジェクトを実施
したりあと他にも国内でもいくつか活動し
てるんですけれどもそういった活動を通し
て私なりに地域のレジデンス力を高める
ためにはどういうことが必要かということ
をちょっとまとめてみました
まず1つはその地域ですねその地域社会を
知るということです
その地域の社会自然環境ってことをまず
知らなければ何が大事かそして何が課題な
のかっていうのがなかなかわかりません
そしてそう言って知った後にですねじゃあ
そういった課題に対してどう自分が対応
することができるのかそしてそれを考えて
自分一人だけではもちろん難しいので地域
の人たちとどういうふうに協力できるのか
自分自身がどういう役割なのかそういった
ことを理解しながら活動を進めていくと
いうことが大事かなと思います
でこういったことはいわゆる地域の
レジデンスを高めるだけではなくてですね
いわゆる最近言われているウェル
ビーイングを実現するためにもこういった
要素は重要かなということが分かってきて
います
最近メディアで色々ウェルビングっていう
ことをお聞きすることがあるかなと思うん
ですけれども
改めて
ウェルビーイングの定義を少し紹介したい
と思います
Who世界保健機関で
ウェルビングっていうものが定義化され
てるんですがそこでは
身体
精神社会的な健康というものが
ウェルビングっていうことに
定義化されています
またいくつかの研究があるんですけれども
ウェルビンゴを高めるために何が重要なの
かっていうことをハーバード大学では約
75年間にわたって追跡調査した研究が
ありましてそこで明らかになった結果とし
ましては
結局いい人間関係が重要っていうことが
明らかになっています
OECDの方ではウェルビーイングを評価
するために加盟国の38カ国それぞれここ
に上がっている11の指標を用いて
ウェルビーイングの評価っていうものが
定期的にされています
その中でですね日本も評価されてるんです
けれども日本が最も
課題であるということで指摘されている
ポイントがあります
それがいわゆる社会的な
側面になります
こちらの
グラフ少しちょっと見づらいかもしれない
ですけれどもいわゆるこのOECDって
書かれているところが平均値でジャパン
ですねこちらが日本の値になるんです
けれども右に行くほど高得点で左に行く
ほど
低い評価になってるんですがここで示され
ていますように日本で評価が低いっていう
ところで言うと仕事と生活のバランスの
時間であったりあと社会とのつながりです
ねその点が他の加盟国に比べて低いという
評価になってしまっています
先ほどハーバード大学の
研究の結果ではレジリエンスの中で重要な
のは人間関係というところがありました
けれども一方レジリエンス力をの高める
ために何が重要かっていう研究もありまし
てこちらはですね
心理学の研究分野でかなり長く研究されて
います
そこで明らかになっているポイントとして
は
内的システムと社会的システムこの
側面が非常に重要と言われています
社会システムというのは先ほどありました
ハワード大学の研究結果に近いんですが
いわゆる人間関係社会的な側面ですね
つながりです
もう一つは内的システムいわゆる自分自身
の精神的な仕組みのところの問題です
こちらのスライドで表しているのは同じく
心理学の研究分野で第一人者である
いろんなモニュエル博士によって
レジリエンスというものがどういうこと
かっていうことを示しているものです
いわゆるレジリエンスには回復していく
ために3つのステージがあるというふうに
言われています
この今状態はリズリエス力が低い状態に
なっています
いわゆる外的ストレスがあって
心が沈んでしまってもなかなか元に戻れな
いっていう状況ですね
それをレジリエンス力を高めるためには
いわゆる立ち直ってそれを教訓化すること
が大事というふうに言われています
こういった教訓かまで
持ち上げるためには何が重要かという
ところで先ほどの社会システム内的
システムになるんですけれども社会との
つながりそしてその社会における自分自身
の役割っていうことを認識することそして
自尊心自己効力感を高める必要性があると
いうことが指摘されています
こういった状況なんですけれども日本で
ちょっといくつか課題がありますこちらは
内閣府の調査なんですが日本の若者意識の
国際比較ということで社会で何かあった時
に自分自身がその問題解決に関わりたい
かっていう質問です
その結果残念ながら日本は非常にそう思う
と
答えた方は
低い状況になっています
またこれは日本財団によって調査された
研究結果なんですが同じく日本の若者の
意識調査で例えば自分には人に誇れる個性
があるかっていうことも非常に低い状況
ですし自分は他人から必要とされているか
についても
自分のしていることには目的や意味がある
かということについても残念ながら低く
自分の人生には目標や方向性があるかと
いうところも低い
そして最後日々の生活で不安や憂鬱を
感じるかっていう点については残念ながら
高いというような結果になっています
こういった日本のちょっと若者意識の
課題を受けてですね私自身がいろんな
ベトナムであったり国内のフィールドで
自分自身のレジリエンス力を高めた経験を
少し
参考にしつつできるだけ大学の学生を
プロフィールドに連れて行くような
取り組みをしています
今は人と地域を元気にするプログラムと
いうものも開発したりもしています
なかなかすぐには難しいところもあるん
ですけれども
地域で何か活動していく中でレジリエス力
が高まるんじゃないかっていう仮説をもと
に今研究をしてるんですけれどもここで
いう地域っていうのは何も自分が住んで
いる地域だけではなく近年
ICTが
技術が進んでますのでいろんな
遠方での地域の活動ってことも実施する
ことができます
私自身ベトナムがその地域の一つになって
います
ですので皆様もどこか自分がすごく居心地
がいいなっていう地域を探していただいて
何か活動をすることで
ウェルビームレジリエス力が高まるんじゃ
ないかなっていうところを今回の
プレゼンで少しアイディアの一つとしてご
紹介したいなと思っています以上ご清聴
ありがとうございました
[拍手]